we have a clip named japan's coffee is
bottom tier because
probably not well we do now yeah we do
now it's coffee we talked about japan's
coffee yeah [ __ ] awful it's
awful it is i i japan truly is a tea
society
yeah i didn't know that i cared about
coffee until i moved to japan and i
realized that the coffee here was [ __ ]
because i thought living in england my
i'm not i'm just like whatever
i would [ __ ] i thought i thought like
my coffee tolerance was
i'll [ __ ] take instant coffee if i
need to but yeah yeah like when i moved
to japan i've realized
what [ __ ] coffee tastes like but then i
got a job
and now i know because remember the the
[ __ ] like
just the brainwashing that happens the
first time you come to japan you're like
i can buy a hot coffee at a vending
machine oh my god i'm gonna buy this
every [ __ ] day oh my god
then you realize it's just all sugar
yeah you realize it's all crap
yeah like oh starbucks has never been so
[ __ ] attractive to me so yeah so yeah
actually
yeah you know as you know japan has like
a [ __ ] ton of vending machines like
everywhere yeah and i remember whenever
i used to go on holiday in japan
i'd always get the coffee uh vending
machine coffee every single day
without without fail and i'm just like i
will never get bored of this at all this
is [ __ ] amazing
i don't need to i don't need to go to a
[ __ ] starbucks or a coffee shop to
get my coffee i can just go to a vending
machine and then i moved here
and then i don't know what it is about
moving here like something switched in
my brain right and then i just instantly
recognized it
as like oh this tastes like crap this is
this is processed instant coffee [ __ ]
and i don't know i don't know why i
don't know what switched my brain like
why is it that when i was here as a
tourist i was
vending machine coffee and vending
machine drinks were just like [ __ ]
like five stars we don't have in the uk
so you're like you're
like amazed it's just like a new weird
thing right like you know conor i
remember was talking about how
you know every time every time you came
here to visit you would [ __ ] eat
you know family mart or nigeria every
day right yeah yeah and then you
realized
oh this is not that great actually i've
actually gone back
on it now oh really i've got i've talked
about like a drone yeah
i was very diehard sandwiches for like a
year and a half and now i'm like man i
just crave rice now what the [ __ ] is
going on
i mean they only use a [ __ ] gravy
dude yeah yeah they're honey is great i
mean i've never been off them
um yeah i realized i just sound like a
druggie right there
how many is too much going back to the
coffee right for me
coffee is as much of like a smell thing
as it is a drink thing like i need the
reason why i like going into a coffee
shop
is because i need that that wall of
coffee smells yeah
that's what makes me feel like i'm ready
to [ __ ] drink i i i'd say i
coffee is a [ __ ] morning thing for me
right now because
not a morning a [ __ ] morning it is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] morning because
honestly honestly is your morning really
started if you don't have a coffee
because to me
if i don't have a coffee that's like
that's like my indicator that my morning
has begun
i can begin the day if i don't have the
coffee then i'm just like in permanent
like
50 brain modes no coffee i sleep coffee
exactly that's literally how i am i
don't know i don't know if it's a
placebo thing no
i'm i'm totally the same like like i
remember there was one week where i was
like
i might be a little too dependent on
coffee let me let me let me back it up a
bit
yeah because i was having like you know
two three cups of coffee a day
right so i was like like four or five
yeah right and i'm like that's probably
not that good for me my heart's probably
about to explode so let me like let me
just go a week
with no coffee and see how i do day two
i was like
i was getting just insane migraines in
my head i was like oh
like i'm really [ __ ] dependent on
this [ __ ] to start the day
i just get sluggish if i stop i don't
really get too bad
how it feels for me is that you know
that scene in the film
where it's like it's like like they got
the grayscale filter on it
that's how i see the world before i have
my coffee man and then
like i they instantly turn up the
saturation
that that is that is how my mornings
work i go from grayscale to sepia
you are after the [ __ ] meme of uh
don't talk to me until i've had my
coffee
like you're literally that guy because i
remember when i first moved to japan
and i my mornings were just like so
depressing because i didn't have that
first
that first good hot coffee to look
forward to right right
because even if i'd go to my like family
mart to get a coffee it was like really
watered down coffee wasn't it
i don't know it's it's i've noticed the
more i like the
the more i like grow up it's the little
things in life that you need to look
forward to
i don't know it is little things like my
mornings are
20 less happy if i don't have a coffee
to look forward to
yeah i just feel like my day is
depressing that's kind of about it
really yeah yeah exactly that's like
most days it doesn't really happen
one time i went to an italian restaurant
here and you know i feel like an italian
restaurant
i feel like you can almost judge it on
uh how good their espresso is with the
meal oh yeah
it must end on espresso i feel at least
like you know yeah absolutely and uh
you know it was good it was pretty good
food i was like not bad have you have
you found one that has a good espresso
because i've
yet to find one there's one or two that
you know if i see the the
actual espresso machine in the back i'm
like nice yeah you know it's going to be
good because they've
they've gone to the effort to get this
ridiculously expensive machine
yeah just for this like one part of yeah
right right yeah
um but i i was i was eating that and the
food was pretty good you know i was
disappointed and i thought well
fantastic would end my meal off with an
espresso and it said on the menu it said
espresso
all right it was a double or a single
and so i ordered the double espresso
and they they just brought out
essentially an americano
what and i said i said like oh no no i
ordered the espresso like i don't know
that's the espresso
and i'm like what it's like this this
talk
i'm like that's not an espresso and if
it is i'm going to be having a heart
attack
it's like a triple double espresso i'm
like what am i the [ __ ] here
are you gonna make me pay for this i'm
not paying for this
i paid for it but you know i didn't walk
out
and naturally i didn't complain and i
paid for it but that's not the point i
mean i was very disappointed was that at
least a good americana no he's awful oh
[ __ ] that day onwards i i swore
against ordering coffee in places where
i couldn't visibly see an espresso
machine
in the establishment i'm like take me to
the back take me to the back see what's
going on come on
yeah because i'd say like the best
purchase i've made in japan
bar none is the nespresso machine i'm
gonna get that soon
i would trade my first born son for an
espresso machine honestly straight up
like i
that thing i i hug that thing yeah every
day
give it a morning kiss i could go
homeless and the one thing i'd keep with
me is the inspiration i'd be going
around on the street holding the
espresso machine plugging into outlets
when i can
just to get a coffee